So, how does a neuron work? To answer that, we first need to know the different
parts of the neuron, because each has a different function. Then, we can take a
more detailed look at precisely how the neuron fires. Which is what we call an
action potential. First, we have the cell body or the soma, it contains the
nucleus and genetic information, along with components for the maintenance and
function of the neuron. These are the dendrites. They're finger-like branches
that project from the soma to connect to other neurons and receive messages.
Extending out from the soma, on the opposite side of the dendrites, is the
axon. The axon transmits electrical impulses towards adjacent neurons and
stimulates the release of what we call neurotransmitters, we'll get to those in
a second. Some axons have a myelin sheath wrapped around them. The myelin
sheath insulates the axon and makes the nerve impulse more effective. At the
end of each axon are the axon terminals, and the terminal buttons. The terminal
buttons contain tiny vesicles or sacs that contain neurotransmitters. Now, I'm
going to zoom into these terminal buttons so we can get a closer look at the
neighboring neuron and how the two connect.